if you were on death row what would you
choose to be your last meal it can be as
long and elaborate as you would like
thanks I would choose sweet little
Alisa's lasagna no question fresh
lasagna I don't know probably couldn't
couldn't order it on death row I guess
if I asked Alisa really Ma you ruined my
life you're a serial killer I don't it's
really bad but I will make you your Las
you m I will do that that final final
wish that you have it is fresh pasta
obviously you roll it out with the
double zero flour and everything you
know and then but but the key to this
lasagna is it's not a regular lasagna
it's beef and pork in the bolog sauce
nice little carrot in there too and you
know just a nice little bolog and then
bashal and then obviously the parmesan
and and stacked up very nicely that
would that would be my last meal no no
question